aujourd'hui il se passe un truc de
dingue je t'ai parlé il ya quelques
temps si tu as regardé les vidéos c'est
à regarder là il y avait une vidéo sur
bois de sapin et expliqué que what's app
était devenu statut j'étais si fait une
vidéo sur instagram où je t'ai expliqué
que instagram était venue il ya quelques
temps de ça tu le sais déjà instagram
stories et maintenant tu as le carrousel
d'instagram et on a aussi dit que toutes
ces nouvelles fonctionnalités qui au
final faut savoir toutes les applis font
partie du géant facebook
toutes ces nouvelles fonctionnalités ont
un seul et unique but le but principal
c'est de faire la nique à snapshot
pourquoi parce qu'il ya quelques années
mark zuckerberg a voulu racheter
snapshots d''achat' a dit pas question
du coup il a les nerfs et comme snap
chaque rentrer en bourse en ce moment
est déjà rentré en bourse d'ailleurs il
y à pleins d'offensive pour lui nuire
alors il ya eu regard si tu te souviens
on en a déjà parlé
facebook qui appartient à mark
zuckerberg a lancé ya quelques temps les
stories directement sur instagram
ensuite on a eu on a eu beau de sap avec
les statuts tout ça pour copier bien
évidemment snapshot
et qui c'est qui voilà aujourd'hui qui
va venir faire la nique un peu plus ses
messenger et ouais c'est tout nouveau
facebook messenger s'émancipe davantage
de facebook et devient une appli à part
entière c'est à dire qu'à partir
d'aujourd'hui tu peux faire des stories
exactement comme sur ce mail chat et je
vais te montrer que ça ressemble ça
c'est un smartphone on y va alors je me
connecte je me connecte directement sur
mon messenger dans la partie du haut tu
vois ce que facebook appelle ma journée
c'est un statut qui s'affiche pendant 24
heures et qui au bout de 24 heures
disparaît yens la photo il ya de la
vidéo tu peux rajouter des émoticônes tu
peux rajouter du texte tu peux changer
les couleurs il ya plein de fils en tout
à cinq mille cadres effet et
autocollants différents autant dire que
tu fais ce que tu veux tu peux en être
une chiée c'est énorme
on va commencer par regarder la démo de
de l'apli partager ce que vous faites en
ajoutant des photos et des vidéos à
votre journée tout ce que vous ajoutez
disparaîtra au bout de 24 heures c'est
bizarre ça me rappelle déjà quelque
chose
contrôler qui peut voir ce que vous
ajoutez à votre journée dans les
paramètres et maintenant tu peux tester
directement bas donc tu testes tu
appuies et là tu te vois à salue donc là
je me vois donc effectivement je peux
changer ma caméra d'un côté ou de
l'autre
je peux mettre le flash si je le
souhaite j'ai eu un petit bouton avec un
sourire un petit smiley ça me permet de
choisir un petit peu si tu veux alors ce
qui l a eue c'est les activités un peu
du moment c'est un peu les trucs du
moment donc latin effet de bulle
tu vas avoir des gros yeux donc ça
détecte le visage exactement comme une
force d'âme schatz agent peut mettre des
couleurs donc sur une vidéo c'est hyper
sympa cette dynamique c'est rigolo je
peux me rajouter un cadre avec des
petits coeurs et puis ensuite c'est quoi
le cadre photo ah ouais ça me faire une
espèce de truc un peu bizarre donc tu
peux faire plein plein plein de choses
ça c'est ce qu'à la une mais qui a
obligé de mettre ça sur clic sur ton
petit smiley ans tu peux choisir dans
comment je vais donc comment je vais
balata pas trop la forme la base fois
c'est ok pas trop ben tu dehors ennui
total enfin il ya plein de choses la
gorge nouée
la gorge nouée et à plein plein plein
plein de trucs c'est vraiment hyper
sympa je retourne dans ensuite ce que je
fais bah tu peux dire je poireaute peut
modifier le texte du poids aux jo plus
j'y pense plus gip en plein de choses
qui au boulot donc tout ce qui
correspond à ta journée si tu veux les
différents moments de la journée
tu peux vraiment la séquence et tu peux
séquence est ajournée et au final tu
peux rajouter plein de choses il des
invitations qui road trip qui a les
crocs pour aller bouffer enfin c'est
vraiment hyper hyper sympa très bien
pensée très bien léché très très
esthétique devrait design donc
ça sort ça change un petit peu par
rapport à ceux naples effectivement août
à des filtres ou tu as toutes les
reconnaissances raciale ou tu pars au
tce de rigolo là l'idée voilà c'est
vraiment de séquence est ajournée et tu
vois vraiment où est ce qu'ils veulent a
laissé toute la journée tu n'utilises
détient un truc tu utilises et que ce
soit hyper convivial fans au quotidien
donc là trop mimi bon un peu youpi youpi
lol c'est maxi lol enfin bon un petit
peu un peu un peu de jeunes ça mais
c'est quand même sympa je kiffe
alors là on est vendredi donc tu as
forcément vendredi y est c'est lourd
bande de potes c'est le week end
ah ça c'est très très ado quand même les
déguisements tu peux te faire leur petit
masque dans les gros yeux dans les gros
yeux bon bassam écoles par dessus tu as
le pistolet laser que tu peux rajouter
en plus du masque tu peut les superposer
indépendant m en seul donc au final qui
crée vraiment l'animation que tu veux tu
as ensuite les décorations
tu peux rajouter de la déco son côté des
petits éclairs tu peux mettre un petit
vélo des boules puantes
une chouette d'un bouquet de fleurs un
truc au trésor une licorne à mondiaux
les licornes tu peux les agrandir tu
peux y retourner
tu fais ce que tu veux tu peux être
hyper créatif et tu peux vraiment créer
un propre monde c'est très très sympa tu
peux mettre des bulles pour t'exprimer
tu peux rajouter du texte alors à c'est
pareil il a donc tu vas dans le texte tu
peux te mettre un petit what the fuck
classique tu peux changer voilà il est
dans ta bulle au milieu alors là blanc
sur blanc ce n'est pas terrible tu peux
changer la couleur de ton what the fuck
comme sur ce match at comme si bizarre
tu défilent le curseur voilà up bim un
petit bien rouge c'est sympa tu termines
tu le mets dedans tu l'as grandis tu
tournes tu le pilote tu fais ce que tu
veux et tu as plein plein plein d'effets
différent tu peux mettre différents ou
hajek tu écris ton texte tu te fais des
bulles donc tu peux en réalité du moment
où tu te lèves au moment tu te couches
tu peux tout commenter tout ce que tu
fais je fais pipi caca je suis au boulot
je suis dans le métro je suis dans le
bus je mange
tu peux tout m c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être même un peu trop mais en tout
cas des possibilités sont là et tu fais
ce que tu veux tu crées ton monde et tu
peux le partage est là dessus c'est
génial tu as la palette artistique où tu
peux je ne sais pas quoi faire dessiner
dessus sur un fond je pense que tu peux
mettre une photo sur un fond rouge pour
moi tu peux faire je maîtrise pas encore
inventé une palette de fonds tu peux
rajouter des effets tu peux tu peux
faire plein de choses il ya si tu veux
énormément de possibilités et c'est tout
nouveau donc là en réalité on est
vraiment dans les tous premiers
utilisateurs et donc après pour publier
on va essayer d'en faire une belle voie
là aurais je du texte you up on va se
coller un petit au jaune ok on va se le
mettre dans une bulle comme ça yo je
clique sur la flèche ça va me l'a
proposé je peux choisir si je veux donc
je peux cliquer sur ma journée donc pour
semble enregistre dans la journée sur 24
heures et après ça les fasse je clique
sur pellicule si je vais aussi
enregistrer la photo directement dans
mon téléphone je peux envoyer sous forme
de messages directement quelqu'un que je
vais choisir dans la liste ça c'est
complètement possible et 6 cliquer sur
la petite bulle à côté de ma journée
le petit rond avec trois petits points
devant ça peut me permettre de savoir
qui va la regarder
donc je peux dire personnalisé et à ce
moment là je vais choisir qui va pouvoir
voir l'image peut vraiment faire un tri
par rapport à mes amis facebook
et sinon je clique tout le monde sauf et
je vais exclure les gens si je veux tout
le monde le voit sauf ce que tu ne veux
pas tu peux choisir pour moi je le mets
à personnaliser tout le monde le verra
je m'en fou et ensuite je fais envoyé sa
part directement et quand je regarde
élevage et celui que j'ai créé tout à
l'heure juste avant de commencer la
vidéo pareil tout à l'heure et le fameux
you qu'on va tout de suite qui défilent
et qui ensuite au bout de 24 heures va
dégager de mon écran voilà comment
facebook a une fois de plus fait la
grosse nick a snapshot la nouvelle
offensive après instagram whatsapp
maintenance et facebook messenger je
pense que fait il
directement va le proposer parce qu'il
n'y a aucune raison que dans l'ensemble
des applications de mark zuckerberg
facebook son réseau social star ne
s'attaque pas directement frontale il ya
messenger c'est une façon de s'y
attaquer par facebook mais c'est pas
réellement de la frontale satar mais
aussi directement facebook messenger de
s'émanciper facebook de proposer un
autre service de garde et les gens plus
longtemps sur les applications et
d'enrichir ses produits et pour poser
toujours des nouvelles fonctionnalités
c'est juste dingue
donc là je suis sûr qu'il va encore y
avoir d'autres offensives
il faut savoir qu'il ya un autre site
qui en france n'est pas trop connue qui
s'appelle médium et qui a aussi proposé
une fonctionnalité de stories pour la
formation mal mais en france
effectivement on connaît davantage un
star whatsapp messenger est forcément le
leader dans le marché pour l'instant en
tout cas
snap chatte et qui à mon avis a du souci
à se faire dis moi ce que t'en penses
utilise la télé certaines nouvelles
versions et dis moi ce que t'en pense un
tu mets un commentaire tu me dis
laquelle tu préfères parce qu'au final
maintenant tac l'embarras du choix
il est sûr que si tu utilises un spa
quitté l'islande mook donc messenger
quelque part ce match at ça risque de
dégager d'autant plus que si tu es sur
facebook tu vas avoir tous tes amis
directement dessus donc beaucoup plus de
personnes à qui de porc des interactions
et c'est là la grande force de facebook
par rapport à ça c'est qu'il a déjà tout
le monde de suite à des millions
d'utilisateurs qui vont se pencher là
dessus a un petit peu moins de monde là
sur what's app
mais facebook c'est une machine de
guerre ça va être en rouleau compresseur
pour snapshot je sais pas si nokia doit
réussir à s'en sortir
je te lis dans les vidéos précédentes
maintenant il va falloir que ce nachat
rebondissent propose de nouvelles
fonctionnalités encore plus riche plus
enrichie sortir un petit peu des copier
coller qui sont faits pour vraiment
proposer quelque chose de neuf et qui va
lui permettre de survivre et tirer son
épingle du jeu
dis moi ce que t'en penses abonne toi ma
chaîne regarde cette vidéo qui est aussi
très sympa merci d'être là je te dis à
très bientôt et je laisse le mot de la
fin à notre ami facebook messenger
ciao